Ukrainian embassies and consulates around
Europe are on heightened alert
after being targeted
with suspicious packages
that include blood soaked
envelopes and animal parts.
This comes just days after a letter bomb
sent to the Ukrainian embassy
in Madrid exploded,
injuring a Ukrainian employee.
Ukraine's foreign
minister says he believes
this is a well-planned campaign
of terror and intimidation.
And CNN's Matthew Chance spoke to him
Well, it started with an explosion
at the embassy of Ukraine in Spain.
But what followed was
this explosion was more weird
and I would even say sick
because we started receiving letters
with eyes, animal eyes cut off animals.
Animal rights, yes, in some cases.
In one case, it's
most probably an eye of a cow
and an eye of a pig in another case.
Let me ask you, who do you suspect?
Who does Ukraine suspect
of being behind this? Well,
of course, I feel
tempted to
say to name Russia straight away,
because,
first of all,
you have to answer the question,
who benefits from that?
And
it's definitely this campaign is aimed
at sowing fear and terrorizing
Ukrainian diplomats.
Your infrastructure of the country
has been attacked repeatedly
by Russian missiles.
You've got an anti-aircraft system
that is straining
to overcome those incoming attacks.
How concerned are you
that this country will be unable
to survive the winter
unless Patriot missiles systems from
the United States
are deployed to this country?
I'm not concerned at all.
We will survive.
I do not have any single doubt
that we will get through this winter.
The question is,
what will be the price
of getting through this winter, winter
and definitely having patriots,
having
other advanced air defense systems
delayed, being having them
delivered in Ukraine within weeks,
not months.
Will dramatic
and lower the price
and will allow us to defend our cities
and our critical energy infrastructure?
Are you concerned that the approval
for those patriots
has not been given yet?
Well,
patriotism became a symbol
The you know, this is a US technology,
but now time has come to make decisions.
So we are having this discussion.
And yes,
I will not conceal
that it will be a huge help.
It would really help us
to defend the country
and to minimize the price
we are paying for surviving
during the winter.
You heard President Biden
yesterday in a press conference with
with the French leader
suggesting that he would be prepared
to sit down
and speak
with President
Putin of of Russia
to try and find a negotiated end
to this conflict.
How did that make you feel
as a Ukrainian,
that the American president
was suggesting that he would be open
to that conversation?
Well, I think you missed one point
from President Biden's remark
because he said that this can only happen
if Putin
is ready to withdraw from Ukraine.
And this is a very important detail
because if
any leader of the world is ready
just to sit down with Putin and talk
behind our back, that is a problem.
But if the conditions
for the conversation
is the withdrawal of Russian army
from Ukraine and restoration
of our territorial territorial integrity,
we are fine with that.
Do you believe there is any possibility
Finally, the final question.
at this stage,
any sign
of the green shoots of a peace process?
Is there anything that gives
you hope on that front?
No.
As we are anticipating another massive
missile attack by Russia
and the goal of this attack is to kind of
bring total destruction
to our energy system.
I don't think countries behave like this
if they want genuinely want peace.
And as long as Putin prefers war,
we will prefer to fight and defeat him.
On the battleground
All right.
I want to bring in
former CIA chief of Russia operation,
Steve Hall.
Steve,
thanks as always for being with us.
I want to
begin by getting your reaction to the
this disturbing reporting
we just heard, blood-soaked
envelopes, animal parts
being mailed to Ukrainian embassies.
What do you make of that?
I think I have to agree
with the Ukrainian foreign
minister there.
I mean,
you know, there's
I suppose
there are a lot
of different possibilities.
And of course,
the investigations will continue
But I think his question is right,
and that is who benefits from this?
And the answer is Russia.
So in addition
to that,
of course,
we know that the Russians
for the longest time
have done released strange and brutal
things outside of Russia
to include assassinating dissidents
and others
who are anti-Putin figures,
shooting them in parks, poisoning them.
So really,
when you look at it in that context
and also the Russians
talk a lot about hybrid warfare,
in other words, nontraditional means
it doesn't it's not too much of a stretch
to think that this is probably
most likely
some sort of Russian activity.
And Steve,
we're also getting
some new reporting today
that Putin plans to visit the Russian
occupied area of the Donbas
region in eastern Ukraine.
Does that tell you
he feels secure
enough about that part of the country
right now? What does it say to you?
No, I don't think it's
an indication of his security.
I think what it's an indication
is, is his really strong desire
to show Russians that, yes, this remains
part of Russia.
Remember, he claims to annex
that part of Ukraine into Russia,
but he doesn't really control
all parts of it.
And many Russians know that
or have questions about that.
And so he wants to go and show that, yes,
this is indeed part of Russia.
Also, I wouldn't be walking around here.
I also think that it's probably
irritating to him to see sort
of a steady
flow of Western visitors
into Kiev and other parts of Ukraine
when, you know, really his his
his military is not doing as well
in the areas that he claims to control.
So I think this is almost more
for domestic consumption
than anything else, Jim.
And he's been doing a lot of that lately.
We saw him meeting
with those Russian mothers days ago
and so on.
And Steve,
President Biden
opened the door
to talking to Putin
if Putin is looking for a way
to end the war in Ukraine.
Biden added
he would also
do it in consultation with NATO's allies.
Moscow in Moscow,
the Kremlin says Putin is, quote,
open to contacts and negotiations.
What do you make of all this?
Yeah, again, I think
the Ukrainian foreign
minister has got it right.
You know,
Biden is not shutting down
the idea of diplomacy,
but he is putting
a very important condition on it,
which is that
if Russia agrees
to withdraw entirely from Ukraine,
then discussions can begin.
You know,
one of the things that you hear a lot
of, Jim, is you hear a lot of politicians
saying, well,
this is Ukraine's decision
And on one level, that's
absolutely right.
And I
it is my great hope
that we continue to provide
as we meaning
the Western United States,
as many weapons and other assistance
we can to the Ukrainians.
That said,
if the West either tires of this or loses
focus on this,
which is what Russia is counting on,
then it's going to be much harder
for the Ukrainians, you know,
to really decide their own fate.
They can really only
decide their own fate
if we give them the tools
with which to do it.
So let's let's hope that that continues.
All right.
Steve Hall,
thank you very much for that time.
We appreciate it.